[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous depuis que suis en
roumanie ça fait 25 ans chaque fois que
je rencontre quelqu'un il me pose
toujours la même question mais pourquoi
es tu venu en roumanie
alors je vais vous répondre quand
j'étais adolescent j'avais plusieurs
rêves je voulais monter ma société je
voulais partir vivre à l'étranger donc
en dehors de la france
je voulais faire de l'import-export donc
en 1994
le jour où j'ai fini mes études j'ai
décidé de vivre mes rêves je voulais
partir à hong kong dans les années 90
hong kong était la plaque tournante de
l'import export
je me voyais transporter des produits
partout dans le monde est à la même
époque mon meilleur ami était venu en
roumanie six mois auparavant
il m'avait dit il ya tout à faire dans
ce pays et tout le monde parle aux
français
j'avais 22 ans j'étais célibataire
j'avais pas un sou dans les poches
j'étais pas mariée n'avait pas d'enfant
elle bat crédit avait pas de maison
j'avais aucune obligation en rouge avait
rien à perdre
par contre vous savez deux choses
j'avais des rêves et j'avais du temps et
donc j'ai décidé d'aller en roumanie à
partir ce moment là dans mon entourage
tout le monde mais absolument tout le
monde a essayé de me décourager de me
faire peur on m'a dit qu'on manie et
qu'est ce que tu vas faire en roumanie
rhmani et des épidémies de choléra en
roumanie tu vas mourir de faim en
roumanie il ya de l'insécurité partout
la terre et corrigée dans la rue ça je
vous assure que c'est vrai je
n'oublierai jamais tout le monde essaie
de me faire peur la seule personne qui
m'a encouragé c'était ma mère elle m'a
dit mais en roumanie si ça te fait
plaisir
de toute façon ça se passe mal je
reviendrai en france et il y aura
toujours une place à la maison j'avais
écouté tous ces gens autour de moi qui
ont essayé de me faire peur et me
décourager je serais passé à côté de mon
destin qui était de vivre dans ce
magnifique pays qu'est la roumaine
la peur c'est la seule
chose qui peut vous empêcher de vivre
vos rêves il ya plusieurs formes de peur
au début quand je suis arrivé en
roumanie
je ne connaissais absolument rien ce
pays mais tu es complètement inconnu je
me suis retrouvé tout seul tout seul
dans un pays qui m'était complètement
nouveau et je peux vous assurer que la
roumanie des années 90 c'est pas le mot
le banat çà et là j'étais mort de
trouille et et je me souviens même que
j'ai pleuré et j'ai découvert ce qu'on
appelle la peur de l'inconnu mais je
savais de choses qui avait beaucoup de
choses à faire et que tout le monde
parlait français en fait ça voulait dire
que c'est un énorme bordel et que rien
et organisée et que les seules personnes
qui parlaient français c'était le
retraité de l'ancien régime
c'est pas tout à fait ce à quoi je
m'attendais donc j'ai dû prendre des
décisions soient j'apprenais à parler
français à 22 millions de roumains
soit j'apprenais à par les romains et
puis a fallu apprendre à s'organiser
dans le désordre la découverte de
l'inconnu
c'est la seule façon de progresser et
d'évoluer depuis ma tendre enfance
on a toujours expliqué que la sécurité
s'était la sécurité sociale et la
retraite
donc quand j'avais 23 24 ans et que je
rentrais en france et je retrouvais mes
amis d'enfance il me disais mais qu'est
ce que tu vas faire pour ta retraite et
comment tu fais pour telle sécurité
sociale mais en fait tu l'avais prévu ni
l'un ni l'autre
et là j'ai été confronté à ce qu'on
appelle la peur du changement j'ai dû
changer de mentalité finalement ce n'est
pas si important que ça la sécurité
sociale et la retraite
j'étais jeune ma priorité c'était ma
carrière puis après on verra bien
au début je fréquentais essentiellement
des français et j'avais très peu de
relations avec les autres nationalités
on a tous besoin un besoin vital
d'appartenir à un groupe un clan et on a
peur d'être rejetés d'être marginalisés
d'être ignorés ou pire encore d'être
humilié et en fait ça s'appelle la peur
du rejet et j'ai appris à vaincre cette
peur est aujourd'hui j'ai des amis dans
toutes les nationalités et
particulièrement des roumains ensuite il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont peur de
s'engager parce qu'ils ont peur des
responsabilités que cela implique
moi par exemple j'étais mort de trouille
à l'idée de marier et je me suis marié
j'avais je vais surtout pas vraiment
fort j'ai un enfant et puis j'avais peur
de perdre ma liberté puis journée plus
ça s'appelle la peur de l'engagement
mais j'ai dû vaincre cette peur pour
pouvoir fonder ma famille et que bien
sûr on a peur de se tromper quand on a
peur de prendre des décisions et
d'assumer ses erreurs ça s'appelle la
peur de l'erreur
mais attention faire des erreurs ça peut
être la plus grande chose qui peut vous
arriver dans votre vie si vous respecter
trois règles reconnaître son erreur
comprendre pourquoi on s'est trompé pour
bien sûr et ça c'est le plus important
ne jamais la refaire on a tous besoin de
reconnaissance de réussite et d'être
admiré on a peur souvent on a peur
d'être de passer pour un loser et ça
nous empêche de prendre des risques ou
deux c'est d'essayer de faire des
nouvelles aventures ça s'appelle la peur
de l'échec
alors l'échec c'est la preuve que vous
avez essayé moi personnellement j'ai
toujours essayé de transformer mes
échecs en de formidable expérience et
vous verrez tout au cours de votre vie
que vous allez apprendre beaucoup plus
de vos échecs que de vos succès et puis
c'est un paradoxe mais il existe une
peur qui s'appelle la peur de gagner
vous lavez et épluchez certains sportifs
au tennis par exemple ils ont deux
balles de match en leur faveur
puis perdre la partie alors ça tout
simplement c'est la peur de l'avenir
c'est la peur d'un lendemain que l'on ne
connaît pas mais qu'est ce qui va
m'arriver
après et puis la dernière c'est la peur
du pire alors la peur du pire c'est la
faculté d'anticiper des situations
négatives la faculté de prévoir et
d'imaginer des situations qui font peur
et qui sont dangereuses par exemple et
s'il se cachait la jambe au ski et si
elle avait un accident de voiture
et si je rap mé les examens
c'est d'actualité alors toutes ses peurs
vous verrez vous allez rencontrer vous
aussi toute votre vie elles vont changer
et évoluer en fonction de l'âge quand on
est adolescent on a peur d'être rejeté
on a peur d'être abandonné par sa petite
amie ou son petit ami on a peur d'être
rejeté par ses copains on a peur d'être
ignorés par ses copains de classe
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est à
l'adolescence qu'on commence à fumer et
à boire et parfois même à se droguer
on est prêt à faire des choses qui sont
interdites et même dangereuse tellement
on a peur de se faire rejeter par les
autres alors vous avez écouté très
attentivement les vrais amis j'ai bien
dit les vrais amis ils ne vont jamais
vous rejetez ils ne vont jamais vous
faire faire des choses interdites et
encore moins des choses dangereuses
quand on a 25 30 ans on a peur de
s'engager
on a peur de perdre sa liberté on
importe se marier on a peur de faire des
enfants ou tout simplement on a peur
d'avoir trop de responsabilités quand on
a 40 50 ans on a peur du changement on
est très attaché à son confort à ses
habitudes
puis quand on a 60 70 ans on a peur de
l'inconnu plus partir mais on a peur de
la mort la mort étant le symbole même de
l'inconnu dans la peur du pire on a peur
tomber malade
on a peur perds ton conjoint on appelle
ce qu'on a peur se retrouver tout seul
alors contre toutes ces peurs il ya des
remèdes
tout d'abord apprenez à avoir confiance
en vous apprenez à vous aimer apprenez à
vous encourager félicite et vous quand
vous faites des choses qui sont
nouvelles
ou que vous avez du succès encouragez
vous quand vous prenez des risques ou
quand vous faites des choses différentes
vous êtes votre meilleur ami
ensuite si vous faites des choses vous
verrez que si vous prenez des risques ou
quoi que vous allez faire
et quels que soient les risques que vous
allez rencontrer au où les peurs qui
vont vous que vous allez avoir dans
votre vie vos parents il vaut toujours
vous aimez vos vrais amis
il vaut toujours resté vos amis et vos
ennemis
ben ça sera toujours vos ennemis alors
si toutefois dans une situation où
quelqu'un vous fait peur ou qui vous
impressionne parce qu'il est grand parce
qu'il est sévère autoritaire alors il ya
une méthode extrêmement efficace vous
imaginez la personne assise sur les
toilettes
le pantalon baissé et vous verrez la
personne sera beaucoup moins
impressionnante n'aurait plus peur
d'elle et ça marche aussi avec les
professeurs alors on va faire un petit
jeu je vais choisir quelqu'un au hasard
dans la salle je vais le pointer du
doigt et celui qui sera choisi viendra
devant moi pour parler et de filmer
après deux millions de personnes donc ça
va être un choix au hasard donc je veux
quand je m'arrête
vous allez voir attention vous avez eu
peur
vous avez vu ce que c'est que d'avoir
tard donc on va faire un petit exercice
moi je connais une méthode qui est très
efficace
chaque fois que j'ai peur je dis même
pas peur donc on va compter jusqu'à
trois je vais dire un deux trois et vous
avez répété tous ensemble le plus fort
possible
même pas peur donc je dis 1 2 3 même pas
peur et après vous me faites péter cette
salle attention hein deux premiers pas
[Applaudissements]
alors pour conclure voici deux thème sur
lequel voici deux thème sur lequel sur
lesquels je vous invite à réfléchir
toute votre vie
écoutez moi bien vous êtes les seuls le
seul architecte de votre vie vous allez
changer de collègues vous allez changer
de copains vous allez changer de
partenaire peut-être que vous allez
changer de mari ou de femme mais la
seule personne qui va vous accompagner
toute votre vie c'est vous mêmes et
ensuite vous allez découvrir et vous
verrez que vous pourrez toujours faire
plus que ce que vous pouvez et que les
seules limites que vous aurez dans votre
vie c'est celle que vous allez vous
fixez vous même alors n'ayez pas peur de
vivre vos rêves
la vie est extrêmement courte et vous
allez vous en rendre compte très vite
profiter d'elle sans avoir peur je
terminerai par cette citation de sénèque
qui dit que la vie est courte que pour
ceux qui durant leur existence n'ont pas
su réaliser leur rêve et je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]